foreign
[Music]
I want to welcome you today to kaijin's
webinar my name is Jovi Chesnick I'm a
senior global market manager here at
kyogen and I will be your host for
today's webinar
the title of today's webinar is
accelerating Sarah's Cove to genomic
surveillance with a new high throughput
NGS solution
this webinar will be presented in two
parts the first part will be presented
by Brian Dugan director of Enterprise
genomic and NGS product management at
kayaja where he will introduce a
Innovative new SARS Cove 2 NGS
accelerated Workforce Solution that
offers several advantages over existing
arctic-based NGS methods including Time
Savings increase throughput and
reduction in plastic wear
in the second portion of our
presentation we'll then move to a
discussion of NGS and other strategies
for viral Wastewater analysis with our
guest researcher Dr Fernando spielke who
is Professor of Urology at Vale
University Novo hamburgo Brazil as well
as coordinator of the Brazilian Network
for sequencing of Cyrus Cove 2.
before we begin please note that all
webinar attendees have been muted during
the webinar to avoid background
distractions however you may use your
question box at any time during the
presentation to submit a question
we will wait until the very end of the
full presentation to answer your
questions
with that it is my pleasure to introduce
our first Speaker Brian Dugan Brian
received his Ms from Georgetown
University in molecular biology
previously Brian worked in marketing and
Business Development positions for NGS
testing as well as in research at the
Eunice driver nichd
Brian is currently a director for
Enterprise genomics and NGS product
management at kyogen well welcome Brian
it's really a pleasure to have you as a
first Speaker today we're looking
forward to your talk
thank you Joby man thank you very much
for everyone for for attending today so
today's talk accelerating genomic
surveillance is the new high-seek group
High throughput NGS solution is our
first webinar that we'll talk about our
newly launched kit archaic direct Stars
cov2 kit this kit will help to speed
genomic surveillance efforts on a
luminous sequencing by being able to to
do things faster in the lab and then and
put more samples on the sequencer really
than typically have been able to do for
the last year
yeah
so quick legal disagreement this
disclaimer kaijin products here are
intended for molecular biology
applications these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of a disease up-to-date
licensing information is available on
the kyogen uh in the kaijin handbook or
kaijin.com
so today's agenda uh is we're going to
start off by introducing the new or Duke
owns for a brief overview of the
pandemic
uh talking about different variants that
are present around the world
second we'll introduce our new Kai seek
direct SARS cov2 kit followed by some
early data that we've generated
internally
and then talk about finally archive in
digital Insight solutions for cersco v2
data analysis
and at the end we'll have a q a session
as well with Dr speaky speakly spill key
sorry
um who has joined us to speak about the
epidemic the pandemic from Brazil
has many facets of products that are are
found in in in throughout this pandemic
from early on the the explosion and the
need for Diagnostic testing
um kaijin Solutions such as isolation
kits for viral RNA isolation PCR assays
point of care testing assays antibody
assays right those are obviously things
that we have seen exponentially grow
over the last year
but really since the end of last year
there has been a global explosion in the
needs for epidemiological
uh surveillance or genomic surveillance
and this has been brought on by the
increasing prevalence of new SARS cov2
variants that have been found to emerge
around the world
now around the globe while many of these
what are called viral variants have
emerged on essentially almost every
continent we have seen that the there's
absolutely a need to expand Beyond just
local PCR testing or local surveillance
and be able to take genomic data and
share it with the world
so Global epidemiology here and genomic
surveillance has really taken on
an unprecedented role in this in this
pandemic
we think back to the 10 years ago to the
bird flu we didn't have the resources
and the sequencing and the
infrastructure we do what we're able to
do now and now we're able to sequence
food samples learn their mutation
profiles learn their lineage and then
share them with the world through places
like gisade or through ncbi and the SRA
uh Repository
and so the information that's being
shared is sequence information whether
you know it's whole viral genome
sequencing or whether it's sequencing of
of the host and the virus
um in in mixed samples whether it's
doing Wastewater sampling and and
looking to to sequence everything that's
in the Wastewater for potential early
detection of some of these viral
variants
sequencing has taken on an unprecedented
role that that we have really never seen
before and when we look at the ability
to actually deliver vaccines and how we
were able to do that in record time we
know that without the sequencing that we
are able to do and and the amount that
we're able to do in that scale is that
we would never have been able to bring
to bear the vaccines and the treatments
that have been made available in record
time
So today we're going to talk
specifically about genomic epidemiology
when we look at though as I mentioned in
the different variants that have that
have emerged around the world
really we're talking about
he is not a strain but slight mutations
or mutations in different areas of the
genome
um specifically most most interest has
been focused around mutations that have
been found in the spike protein as those
right the the vaccines that have been
produced by different companies around
the world whether it's an mRNA vaccine
or protein-based vaccine or some other A
variation of that
the spike protein is the Target by which
right those vaccines are looking to to
put our immune system into overdrive
and so starting at the end of last year
where it became more sequencing became
much more apparently needed because of
the emergence of first the b117
and the b1351 because of the thought
that those variants specifically which
became very public at the end of last
year
um were were more transmissible or
potentially more virulent they also
offered a chance for what's immune you
know a lower immune response or
potential what's called breakthrough
now when we talk about Brazil and Dr
spilki will be able to talk about this
in more depth is that variants have
emerged there in areas um you know in
Brazil such as the P1 variant in the P2
variant but these all of these are not
local right variants are not local
because we have Global Travel and they
have spread around the world
and so all of it's important to be able
to look at this to understand how these
mutations happen and to be able to track
them because some of the mutations that
are found in one region of the world to
emerge have actually emerged all over
the world right because this is an RNA
virus and an RNA virus is essentially
they mutate frequently here
but as this this demand has has
increased exponentially here in the
early late part of last year but we saw
is there was huge actual strain on the
global testing system the PCR systems
had been in place for almost a year but
the sequencing infrastructure the
sequencing testing in some places around
the world who's very good but in many
places around the world we hadn't been
fully developed
so with this with a huge increase in now
a new area we saw significant amounts of
delays in getting products for
sequencing whether it's a library prep
whether it's indexes whether it's
plastic plates whether it's vials
whether it's tips all of that has has
played a role right as being able to
slow down our response and so when we
talk about the kai C direct source code
V2 kit we took all this uh into it you
know into our mind here about thinking
about how to develop a new a new
solution that would fit that that would
that would be able to address some of
those challenges
now I mentioned the fact that that the
the variance of the mutation sorry in
the spike protein here are the ones that
most people think about but when we look
across the entire viral Genome of SARS
cov2 what you see is that there are
different mutations in different genes
across the virus that confer or reduce
some level of Advantage
um they also some of the some of the um
the mutations actually allow for greater
zoonotic transfer there have been cases
that have been reported about transfer
from humans to dogs I think very
famously we've heard about cases of
minks right um an animal that's
typically farmed where they have become
Mass infected there have been cases that
also confirmed that the house cap right
has has received the zoonotic transfer
here
um of our of the virus so we know as we
think about this right mutations in a
virus the virus is trying to mutate a
confirmed advantage in an evolutionary
capacity here and so as we track this
all this is important to understand is
the virus becoming more transmissible is
it becoming more virulent more deadly or
less of those things right all of that
is is pertinent information to have
foreign
but when we look in depth to say one to
to look at the b117 and the b1351 uh
variants of the virus now what v117 has
become the dominant uh mutation mutation
variance in many parts of the United
States where where I reside and we see
that the its ability to you know it is
increased transmissibility right and and
more and more studies are talking about
the fact that 117 actually leads to
significantly increased negative
outcomes
and so it's it's a what's called a
variant of concern right and b1351 while
potentially not being as transmissible
as as one one seven as a mutation found
in the spike protein the e4a4k mutation
um that has been thought to to really be
able to to create some level of uh
antibody Escape right what's what's
termed as breakthrough and so now
vaccine developers are racing to be able
to create new versions of vaccines that
can specifically address some of these
viral mutations
and so what we see here again is another
unprecedented move where we've seen
companies who have specifically mRNA
vaccines are able to quickly spit up new
clinical trials to test some of these
things
and again none of this will be possible
without sequencing here
but you can see that when you look at
the viruses and the mutations that are
found here it's not just in the spike
protein right the signature is across
all areas of the SARS cov2 genome and so
it's important to understand what viral
variant is present and what that lineage
looks like because again we have seen
other mutations actually develop
now from a public health perspective
most of the sequencing that has gone on
globally
has has really been built on what is
called the Arctic protocol the Arctic
network is a network of what I would say
is is researchers who are are into the
into looking at early pandemic response
and that group globally was able to come
together in early 2020 and put together
uh primers and protocols for the globe
to really be able to sequence stars cov2
and to do it effectively and
reproducibility reproducibly right um
using you know any any type of
sequencing platform
now the Arctic based network is so the
art base protocol is a great protocol
overall it's been able to generate high
amounts of of whole genome coverage
right and kyogen has has since last year
and had a solution that is based on the
RF protocol which is our Kaya cxr's cov2
primer panel plus archaic FX DNA Library
prep kits
this is a great protocol because it
generates 400 base pair amplicons right
so it's compatible with a Oxford
nanopore technology or longer read
sequencing Upstream but really you know
when you use the highest input machines
there's aluminous sequencers you pair
that with our alumina compatible Library
prep kit or any Library prep kit and you
you sequence the whole genome of the
virus
but there are some challenges that have
come with that workflow um the Arctic
workflow requires fragmentation or
tagmentation they're ligation-based
workflows
um and you know the workflows themselves
can take actually a number of days when
you're especially when you're doing a
large number of samples
so with that we're introducing our
chiacy direct Stars cov2ket which is
really taking the idea of what um the
great workflow that Arctic has built
right but really instead of it being 400
base pairs in design for long read and
compatible with short read a Luna
sequencing we've built it to
specifically be designed for high
throughput Illumina applications that
has an Innovative of four hour total
workflows that includes RT cleanups that
you need to do
um and and is is built with overlapping
amplicons that reduce the risk of
mutation redrop out it reduces Hands-On
time and reduces the need for more tips
right and it's a true single box
solution so essentially you can
guarantee the security of of your supply
chain here
but now I'm going to go into more depth
about our new Kai C direct source code
V2 kit
so I mentioned some of the pain points
here
um with the original kit and so what
we've done to be to be more specific is
that our new Kai seek direct Stars cov2
kit has no fragmentation ligation or
tagmentation that's necessary
it uses a a small number of universal
pcr-directed indexes with unique tool
and with unique dual indices here right
um that allows you to go through this
workflow extremely quickly right so
without the need to fragment without the
need to do ligation right you have you
create a huge amount of Library uh um in
this in this free option
you know by consolidating this by
eliminating fragmentation by eliminating
ligation right we've been able to do
that and to essentially to reduce it
says plastic wear but the main the main
bottleneck here is tips right the tip
usage is about 45 of what the typical
Arctic or longer protocols look like
when we compare it from side by side
now again this becomes extremely
important if if you as someone testing
in a lab right are having challenges of
finding tips or getting tips and we know
this is something of whether you're
doing manual pipetting or you're doing
High throughput automated pipetting that
becomes a challenge
now mentioning the original Arctic
workflow here we talked I talked about
the fact that it is a flexible uh
workflow that is compatible with you
know an Oxford workflow an expert
nanopore right Upstream of an Oxford
data for Library prep kit
um right but then it is compatible with
Downstream solutions for for a Lumina
sequencing
but when you look at the primers right
do they generate 400 base pair amplicons
that are typically right are are
certainly something that you can do with
luminous sequencing but when you think
about targeted applications on a
luminous sequencing you typically don't
generate 400 base pair amplicons it's
easier to generate something smaller so
you don't have to to fragment nearly as
much
and so with that we looked at the um you
know this that we took the same
methodology from a primer design point
of view and the algorithm design our
primers as the Arctic Network used what
we did was instead of doing 400 base
pair amplicons we generated 250 base
pair amplicons here
that's smaller amplicon sizes mean that
it immediately fits a little bit nicer
in terms of Illumina sequences that also
eliminates the need for the
fragmentation right or anything else
that that adds time and adds effort and
work to the reaction
that the primers themselves here though
are you know there is some overlap in
terms of the Arctic primers
and really at the end of those ant long
amplicons so looking at the increasing
prevalence of some of these viral uh
variants that are emerging in the
different mutations that are showing up
all around the genome we know how
important it is to actually to have
essentially a safety net here and so in
some areas of the genome we have built
overlapping and staggered primers that
are designed to essentially to to have
higher and redundant levels of coverage
should should an actual mutation affect
an individual um a primer site at the
three prime end
the final piece that that I'll talk
about here is that at launch we have 384
unique dual indices but within the next
month it will have a double that in
terms of 768 Duty eyes
now while the amount of samples that you
may want to run on say a large
throughput sequence such as the novaseq
right is may not be thousands of
thousands of samples if you're currently
looking at Solutions where you have Bank
samples and want to run this at a large
scale this gives you flexibility to
essentially to drop the cost of your
sequencing reaction by half and double
the multiplexing so this is true of
whether you have a next seek right which
can generate 400 million on paired and
reads whether you have a Nova C guess
prime or you have an S4 flow cell right
all this allows you to double the
multiplexing that's available here
now from a workflow point of view I have
talked about the Arctic workflow and
again kyogen has has released a our
chi-seeks Our Stars Kobe 2 primer panel
which is based on the Arctic workflow
um and so on the bottom here what you
see is the original Kai cxrs cov2 primer
panel plus FX workflow what you see is
that it is a long workflow right um you
know originally when we looked at the
timing of this we thought it would you'd
be able to do it shorter than it was but
in real practice has what we have seen
is that essentially it's 10 to 16 hours
depending on the number of samples that
are being processed simultaneously
um and so with that right again there's
things like multiple bead cleanups that
are there
um you know fragmentation uh the
enrichment stats all this stuff takes
time that we wanted to essentially to
clean up
and so with that we've been able to do a
few different things to to create this
four to five hour workflow with our new
Kai seek direct kit
so as I talked about early on is that
there were some workflow challenges that
became very apparent when speaking to
our customers there were uh there were
challenges when it came to cdna
synthesis when it came to enrichment
um customers asked if we could remove
bead cleanups if we could remove
quantification normalization right and
then also asked us about primer design
and so when we when we got this feedback
here and sequencing really exploded we
we had recognized already there was a
need to solve some of these challenges
and so you know from this all the steps
in the workflow we have improved
something uh and some step here compared
to say another or even our previous
workflow our previous artistic based
workflow is great it's being used in a
number of national programs and it's
been able to sequence the virus to high
degree right a high fidelity with high
viral genome coverage around the world
right but again there are challenges
right in terms of being able to do it
faster can you do it quicker right is
you have a primer design strategy that
is that reduces some of the pain points
right that I've now talked about so so
essentially what we've done is it's a
look at all of those steps and to try
and improve somewhere to provide value
to customers so they can do a faster
quicker workflow and still generate the
highest quality levels of data
but now I'll talk about archaic direct
Stars cov2 data
and the first thing when we start
looking at at
generating NGS libraries uh of SARS cov2
is it's a talk about what are we doing
here right so we're doing it's Hardware
the whole genome sequencing okay and so
you know if you think about if you're
coming from a human sequencing
background you think about targeted
genomics which is you know taking Gene
panels
um of primers or hybrid capture right
and sequencing you know megabases of of
areas of what you know we have a very
large three gigabase genome here it
stars Kobe 2 as a genome is only 30 000
bases right so from the point of view of
being able to get the full genome is
that you can do this with a targeted
based application this doesn't require
right a library prep kit just that you
hold you know
the samples that we're talking about are
also not clean as well right and so most
of the time sequencing is post-diagnosis
a post diagnostic uh test that is done
after a PCR positive and so those
samples have isolated RNA uh and so then
you're taking that into the reaction but
you have background RNA you have other
things that are actually potentially
there right that you're going to
sequence so you just you're throwing a
whole Library prep kit or an RNA
sequencing kit at it is going to give
you a lot more information that you need
so you're going to do a targeted
approach and here again we use our
primer based approach here to do this
but if I talk about the original our our
original Kai seek um primer panel
methodology here again we talked about
taking this 400 base pair amplicon and
pairing where the library prep
and so if you look at the bottom figure
here right
um what you see here is is what we like
to call the hump and the peak now this
is good quality data that I'm showing
you that's generated here but if you're
used to doing a targeted application
because we would get this question many
many times many customers just say is
this right does this look good right and
the reality is when you take a long
amplicon and you have to fragment it
right fragmentation is not a perfect
reaction augmentation is not a perfect
reaction right and so you have a range
of sample that's there because you have
varying amounts of of of this right and
so you would get the the hump and the
p-chair
but that would so so looking at that
that would mean that that range would
affect your On Target
um concentration of your on-target
libraries right and so some samples you
get really really great Library yields
really really great on target Library
yields and some samples you would see
that number dip or or essentially be a
little bit you know sort of all over the
place and that's that it has to do with
the nature of fragmentation
fragmentation itself right is it can be
incomplete
so by now with the kaiji direct Stars
code V2 Library prep kit is by taking
the specific shorter amplicon approach
that's specifically targeted that has no
fragmentation is we're generating right
High Fidelity focused amplicon and
Library sizes right so there's not
there's not fragmentation that's
incomplete and so what you see here is
when I look at the scale of my library
concentration from the bottom you can
see here that my on my traces is that I
have five times higher amounts of
concentrations that I'm measuring here
on the top that the new direct Stars
cov2 kit compared to the old one so you
should expect that whether you're
working at 100 copies or a thousand
copies that you are going to see a
significant increase in your library
yields
and if you're familiar with sequencing
you know that the higher the library
yields that you have right it's better
diversity that you have and probably the
better representative that your
sequencing data is going to be with that
yeah the other thing too to think about
as I mentioned gifted earlier and when
you submit your your guess a data or
your starts cov2 genomes to guess Aid
right there are minimum standards that
are generally recommended for submission
and acceptance of that and I believe
it's about 20 to 25 uh X coverage and I
think it's 95 of the genome is the
minimum standard right for uh this for
for source code V2 GMS to be accepted to
get saved which I I believe is the case
but essentially you need to have high
quality high amounts of coverage here
right of of the virus to be able to put
in into these these public repositories
and that's for the best right because
that helps everyone get a really clear
picture of of good work that's being
done and to get a good look at you know
the clades of the virus in certain
regions here
when we look at this though we would see
that you know we knew we needed to have
a highly uniform of Kit and something
that's going to deliver high levels of
of Base coverage no matter what the
sequencing depth is right so when we
look at the left side uniformity of our
our new Kai seek directs article V2 kit
compared to our original kind of C
primer panel based solution
what you see here with the blue bar is
that the well actually the Red Bar the
original primer panel delivers high
amounts of uniformity at both 0.1 x and
0.2 X of the mean here
but when you see that there's there's
even a substantial increase right with
the chi State direct service copy 2K
it's because again going back to the
fact that the amplicons and the the
methodology that we we took is focused
uh in terms of amplicon and Library
sizes it's specific right for a short
read sequencing so it allows us to get
better overall coverage right with that
compatibility
now that also means too when we start
looking at the base level coverage here
um and and both of these data sets were
generated with a million clusters right
and so this is this is high depth
sequencing here that we're talking about
here
is that when you do high def sequencing
where you want to make sure is that you
don't have over representation of
certain regions
yeah this was unfortunately an area that
we had already seen in in our original
Arctic workflow that had come out at the
beginning of 2020 and we had actually
made adjustments and primer changes to
that in the middle of 2020 to to
increase low coverage regions
um of our primer panel but there was
still a bunch of you know Peaks and
valleys that you would see because of
the 400 base their amplicons because of
the fragmentation
but again because the new primer design
and the effective effectiveness of this
for sure resequencing what you see here
is that going from the original primer
panel which both again showed high
levels of Base coverage right 98 at 20x
coverage but when I went up to 100x
coverage I would see that drop by about
four or five percent
but with the new Kai seek direct source
code V2 kit you don't see a significant
drop right below 99 here
um with these control samples now this
is important to show that by you know
when you're doing deep sequencing that
you expect to see uniform coverage
across the genome and I'll show that in
just one second
and as I said right earlier we're
talking about looking at mutations
um looking at you know sites where the
PCR testing has gone on but then also
understanding there are some areas of
the genome that have been reported as
having low coverage previously with some
other methodologies here is it so we
took a snapshot of three different areas
of stars Kobe 2 genome the S Gene the
n-gene and the endoruba nuclease gene
the S gene or the spike protein is
obvious why I'm showing this here and so
if you look at the the red bar which is
the original chiasek primer panel the
Arctic based solution what you see here
is that the Peaks and valleys the Peaks
and valleys that comes now you're still
seeing high levels of coverage across
the entire s Gene but the reality is
though that the higher the highs right
or the lower the lows can be Amplified
when you do higher depth sequencing or
you do lower depth sequencing and so
those are always areas of concern when
you start to see some of that difference
if you look at the Blue Bar though the
new direct Stars could be too kit and
you essentially draw a line right at the
top of the Thousand across what you see
is our highly uniform coverage plot
right all across the spike protein you
don't see big dips and valleys here as
compared to to the 400 base their
artist-based amplicon solution and
that's important here right because
again this is going to deliver High
uniformity and High coverage right with
the spike protein
yeah this is true when you look at the
end Gene here as well and we chose the
engine because many diagnostic targets
specifically in the US right targeted
the engine early on and you can see that
you know they actually bulk kits perform
really really well here with the spike I
mean with the engine and so you know
that you're going to get good coverage
that uniformity is there whether using
the primer panel or you're using our new
direct kit
but I also called here back to the
underwriter nuclease Gene and so there
has been a fair amount of discussion if
you've looked in publication and talking
about that there are some areas of the
genome again with arctic-based network
and even some of the high seek solutions
that were early we released early in
2020 where we would see areas of
dropouts and with the endurado nuclease
gene in the prior panel before we fix
this and added more primers to to add
enhanced coverage in the region is that
we would see this region drop right
relative to the surrounding regions both
prior and after uh the ribonuclease gene
and so the mitigation strategy we took
originally was to add more primers on
top of that region and rebattles the
primers from a concentration point of
view and you can see here by the Red Bar
all that delivers high levels of
coverage
but just to reinforce that the kaisi
direct Stars Kobe Q kid delivers the
same type of coverage you can see with
the blue bar essentially right below
that thousand marker here is a straight
line across here just overall right
there's a little bit in terms of of
going above and below right but nothing
really abnormal from a statistical point
of view so all in all you're getting
highly uniform high levels of coverage
across the sarskovich
now when I take a snapshot out right and
look at the what we'll call the 30 000
foot view here it's very difficult to
put 30 000 bases in a snapshot and be
able to show it on the slide but you can
see so it this looks a little bit Jagged
right but if you were to go to igv and
to look at this or it's another genome
browser you can see here in terms of
coverages right is that when you compare
the blue bars to the red bars
right you just see that the blue bars
are much more in line with each other
from a uniformity perspective there's a
little bit more variability with the red
bars to the Arctic based on Solution
that's there and again the kaisi direct
kit delivers its high levels of coverage
all across the genome
now there is one thing you know the both
the five Prime end and the the extreme
five Prime end and the extreme three
prime ends right it is essentially
impossible for any primer based solution
to cover those areas both polyethyl
right and and the first uh you know a
few bases of sarsko V2
um and so those would you see the
Dropout areas are not surprising right
as well see or again extreme five Prime
and three prime net but as there has
been no biological indication that those
areas are of key significance right to
either mutations or phylogeny or clade
calling or anything else like that we
can say that really this covers the
entire rest of the genome here except
for those those first 50 and last 50
bases across SARS cov2
so finally I'm going to talk really
briefly about our archives in service
cov2 Insight service
um
and and what we are doing now is now you
have the ability to use a cloud-based
solution here that supports multiple
different um solutions that are out
there
um kind of seek service code V2 primer
panel as well as the new kai-seek direct
kit which would be launched uh soon for
for this and essentially what we're
doing is we're taking all of of the
knowledge and the capabilities that we
have been built on with kaijin CLC
genomics workbench and now make it a
fast accurate and scalable solution
using Amazon web servers on global
infrastructure so it allows you to
essentially be able to to access the
access this anywhere in the world
you're also able to do is to generate a
whole genome analysis report
and so the great thing with this is that
it allows you to to
um to have information that's specific
to your organization so if you're
looking at delivering this to a national
agency whether you're looking to deliver
a local agency or you're just producing
this
um you know for any any number of
reasons here is you can brand this
um you're able to to put expected QC
metrics on there
um the data analysis and then
information about sequence information
that's used by the workflow and and this
is tied to uh predictions by Pangolin
um and then clade analysis as well as to
produce predicted by next clade
so all in all right uh we're enabling
here A solution that allows both
ultimate weapons chemistry side
um to our digital Insight service side
to deliver Solutions uh really anywhere
that you are
so if I look at this from a high level
point of view
um you know any lab now can perform NGA
space Stars cov2 surveillance at scale
um so you don't need to have a local
installation
um you know you certainly if you have
hydrogen CLC genomics workbench that is
a phenomenal tool that we have built all
of our analysis on and you can continue
to use that however if you are
interested in bringing to scale a
cloud-based surveillance solution right
it's compatible right with you know with
a fast two files trade off your
sequencer right it can help to put
outputs such as PDF reports XML reports
variant files and many other things as
well and so you know you can remain
compliant with things like gdpr that
still deliver these Solutions uh support
whatever whatever you know uh
sequencing efforts that are going on
where you are located
so finally as I close up just to come
back to kaisy direct SARS cov2 kit it
comes in two different sizes here so
both a 96 sample and a 384 sample
um the solution that we have is
formatted similar to many other index
solution kits with an A B C D
nomenclature right and so that these are
each are each of these are all 96
um unique dual indices either format A B
C or D right and all of these can be
multiplexed together now coming soon
um
available in the uh in the later in Q2
will be our second set of indexes you
know e through H again these are another
set of unique dual indices that allow
you to Multiplex up to 768 per uh per
flow cell per Lane of a flow cell so
that you could do massive multiplexing
uh really and double the amount of
sequencing that you can do on on say an
alumina Nova stick right now
where typically you can run over 3000
samples at a time if you wanted to but
you could run over 6 000 samples by
using both of these sets of udis as they
become available
so all in all again this this kit is is
really is made to be able to support
Global sequencing efforts and we
continue to see more and more news about
the importance of of the viral variants
and the mutations that have impact on
vaccines on Health on transmissibility
on all of that right and so uh we we
know that it's important and so we think
that sequencing is important so we
continue to support these with our
Solutions
well as I close up right now uh I'm
being joined by Dr Fernando stilke
um and I think so uh and and Joby will
come back in and we can have a
discussion and a q a
um not only regarding my presentation
but also
um to talk about on the pandemic in
Brazil's in Brazil as well as strategies
Dr spilkey has engaged in for looking at
Wastewater analysis so thank you very
much
thank you so much Brian I think that was
a very interesting uh presentation
especially will be of interest I think
to a lot of people who are interested in
in finding a solution that offers really
uniform coverage to help the research
um I'd like to move on now for the next
portion of our presentation and it's my
pleasure to introduce Dr Fernando's
bilke who is a professor of virology at
female University in Brazil he's also
the coordinator of the Brazilian Network
for sequencing of Cyrus Cove II and he
joins us now for an interview discussion
of the current coved pandemic in Brazil
as well as strategies for viral
Wastewater analysis
Dr spell Keys research focuses on
environmental virology Cyrus Cove 2
Evolution viruses causing relevant
diseases in domestic and wild animals
and emerging zoonotic viruses welcome
Fernando it's great to that you're able
to join us today to give us your
perspective on cyruscove 2 and GS
analysis and especially with regard to
our viral Wastewater analysis which I
think is becoming a very important topic
so thank you so much for joining us
good to be here with you and all that in
this
awesome
um I you know I'd like to
portion with really just a very general
kind of question about what's happening
in Brazil right now
um could you briefly describe the
current covet pandemic situation in
Brazil
oh the situation is just a worrying we
we had not controlled the situation over
the the over time since the beginning of
the pandemic but it became even even
worse in the last few months and I think
that it's it has something to do with
the variants that uh Brian have already
mentioned but also about the the type of
a partial controlling that we had tried
doing this this year the fact is that
the country recorded uh almost 355
000 deaths already and since the
beginning of the pandemic and just to
for you to have a glimpse of the the
size of the problem the moving average
of deaths in Brazil in the last seven
days has about 3 000 deaths per day
which is the worst moving average of
deaths from from the disease ever
recorded in the country so we are I
would say that we are passing through
the the third peak of the disease in
Brazil and the the amount of new cases
and deaths in in the last month were
really really high
we have our friends uh towards stability
investment new cases but the levels are
very high and we have this P dot one p.2
B1 dot 1.7 in many states in Brazil and
the vaccination is going slowly so we
have a lot of work in the next few
months certainly sounds like there's a
lot of urgency for both research as well
as testing and in vaccination
um let me ask you your your research
specialty is virology and in the pastor
lab has performed Wastewater analysis of
various types of viruses so can you tell
me a little bit about the different
types of viruses your lab has analyzed
from Wastewater and the strategies
utilized to perform your your analyzes
well since the the the the end of the
thousands we have worked in my
laboratory with the detection of
different viruses and environmental
mattresses including many viruses
transmitted by water that can cause
gastroenteritis hepatitis and other
diseases in human beings and in domestic
animals we have worked at work along
all this time with Adam viruses enter
viruses rotavirus Hepatitis A
noroviruses and more recently we have
some parts of my
team working with Cisco to detection in
in water and wastewater
we did hear everything from more using
viruses detection in environmental
mattresses and and further sequencing
those viruses to to accomplish something
like microbiosource tracking
trying to to determine what are the
sources of contamination in watersheds
and we also did a lot of
virus-based risk analysis
and one of our works that was widely
implemented in the media was that work
that we made
for the hero Olympics water revenues
which were unfortunately highly
contaminated by viruses and I would say
that environmental virologists and
international area I think that the the
the the application of the the concepts
of environmental virology in terms of
the preemptive or the predictive
surveillance that could be done
is very useful in the case of sarsap2
and we have a lot of possibilities to to
do a better work in terms of controlling
the pandemic if we have also these uh
these two with us
so it's it could be a very good for for
defense of Public Health
as well
are there any lessons that you've
learned from your past Wastewater
analysis
um for that might you might be able to
then apply to the current Cyrus Cove II
Wastewater
analysis that that are currently
starting in your country
well job I think that this is a very
important question as I believe that
some typical challenges of detection of
viruses in environmental mattresses
are sometimes not known or are forgotten
in the analysis of such sculpture
environmental mattresses and especially
in Wastewater
some characteristics of Wastewater may
be critical issues for that matter and
also other environmental variables May
influence the the results and maybe you
have to be taken in account even in the
analysis and the interpretation of the
results
detection of viral genomes with water is
normally not easy as in clinical samples
identification of virally contaminated
water requires a says with sufficient
sensitivity to detect very low copy
numbers of our targets that's that's why
I'm unhappy to see that the solution
provided by by Brian
today shows that you could perform an
engine that's even in very high cities
which is a challenge that will be faced
by those people that will try to make
such an analysis in in in viruses that
are detected in water because normally
they are in very low copy numbers
so this is one of the challenges and
other there are other some inner points
in this analysis that requires also uh
some some
caution especially the the possibility
of PCR Inhibitors that are there
normally because we have sometimes we
have to do concentration of these Waters
and Inhibitors are are
concentrated uh Downstream as well so
you have to take care of it and there
are all the important matters that
regards to the evaluation of
environmental factors that could
influence the results like rainfalls the
percentage of sewage treated in a given
region which is normally high in
developed countries and very low in poor
countries so this could be also
something that could be there when
evaluating the results that we have
and sometimes the levels of detection so
is is of a given virus in the
environment in Sarasota too is more
likely to to behave that way is is not
influenced solely by the number of cases
in a given region but also by by other
factors that could be involved
great thank you that's yeah
interesting I I wondered if
you might be able to speak to the
potential utility of using next-gen
sequencing for SARS Cove to Wastewater
analysis testing
um and you know so people are using
different methods to analyze SARS right
I mean some people using PCR some
digital PCR some next-gen sequencing so
you know how relevant do you think
um NGS is for the purpose of Cyrus Cove
2 Wastewater testing and Analysis and
you know how can it the how can NGS best
be utilized for for this study
well of course uh PCR and digital PCR
could be very good solutions for for
monitoring but
I think I do the rising of new search
goes to variances have been seated by by
Brian like well I think that due to this
matter like NGS from Wastewater may be a
very promising to in the future
especially if we are able to to have
these uh lookup numbers uh at the PCR
being sequenced by a very robust
platform like
so this one that you showed was this
morning and that could be very useful
for for early detection and genomic
surveillance
and this could be very important as to
to mount preventive measures in time
especially in in highly populated areas
because this could allow you to to to
have an alert that I given the variant
of concern or any variant under
investigation is is coming to to this
region so maybe even before
the the clinical cases you could
send this information to the authorities
and
um and this could be very useful for for
prevention of new cases so I think that
this is very promising
for the account
they're coming proves there are a lot of
areas around the world right now that
are struggling still struggling quite
quite a bit with Cyrus Cove too and we
appreciate your insight into the current
situation there
um going on in your country
um I would at this point in time like to
invite our
attendees to go ahead and use your
question box and submit any questions
that you may have thought of during the
presentation we already have a couple
that have come in and we can begin a q a
session and I think uh this first
question then goes to Brian Brian
um maybe you can review this just
briefly a little bit this person asked
is the direct SARS Cove 2 Kit compatible
with nanopore sequencing
uh so that's a great question um so we
have not tested it with manafort
sequencing
um and and this is a Consolidated kit
um so where the primer panel the
original car seat primer panel is
separate so that you could use an Oxford
nanopore Library prep Downstream from
there write purchase from them
um this one is everything you need for a
limited sequencing so the kit is not
really set up
um for uh nanopore sequencing and with
the amplicon sizes being very focused
um you know it could it work potentially
yes um but it would also it would and it
would require all the materials from
Oxford and we don't uh there's nothing
that we know right now that that a
woodworker wouldn't work so it's hard
for me to say one way or the other but
it's not really designed for uh for that
type of sequencing I would recommend
using the primer PAD as being the
primary methodology to do now of course
sequencing ahead of right and officer
Library prep
great thank you
um another question for Brian
um what next seek read lengths are
recommended two times 150
yeah so this is a standard um a
sequencing run uh so two by 150 is the
recommended with it yeah
very good
can um by our same attendee here it is
for is a four hour time to completion
based on manual prep is there a robotic
protocol
yeah so that is based on it is based on
a hands uh Hands-On with a multi-channel
pipette
um so it's about four and a half hours
for 96 samples um because it's you know
essentially working in the plate
um there is a robotic protocol that is
coming um that will be released shortly
within the next month
that will be able to automate it the
automated protocol itself would not have
significant
um Savings in time right it would be
mainly to
um to remove contamination risks and to
make it hands-free
um and the protocol itself should be
mostly be able to be almost all on board
in automated uh platform uh with with
the workflow and the fact that it
doesn't have a lot of it doesn't need a
lot of things to come on and off the
platform uh So within I think by May
um there should be information regarding
um the automation of that the platform
that it's available for
okay thank you
um for Fernando a question here what
method of filtration in viral
concentration are you using for
Wastewater samples
at the same moment we are using Ultra
centrifugation mostly we are not using
uh filtration or or membranes uh
there are all these methods available of
course any laboratory that comes in into
this will have to check what what could
be more useful for their reality but in
our case we are using uh Ultra
centrifugation with very good results
great thank you
um another question I think this goes to
Brian
um the person asked are any of your
coverage figures from actual Wastewater
samples
yeah so this kit was just released this
uh this weekend we were not and and so
we are in the process of generating that
all the data that I showed we're using
control samples
excuse me so we expect to have a another
uh more data Rich uh web webinar um
coming out in May
um that will have information from uh in
an acute
um respiratory infection as well as
Wastewater samples uh right that will be
more in depth in terms of with with CT
values and everything else like that so
this these were from atcc control
samples
thank you
um another question here is the analysis
report AWS service only available when
using the kyogen direct kit
um that's actually a great question
um I I don't believe that it is I'm not
so the bioinformatics team at Kaizen is
different I think they have different uh
kayaking I'm sorry different um starts
W2 workflows
um that will allow you to use an Arctic
based method but I'm not sure if it's
compatible with with multiple different
types of sequencing Technologies right
so I would recommend I'm speaking to a
local hydrogen bioinformatics rep who
can give you more information about this
okay
um another question for Brian how many
reads do you recommend for the kaisy
direct Cyrus CO2 kit
yes this is this is the million dollar
or million read question I should say
um all right so it really depends on
what do you want to do
if you want to do low pass consensus
rebuilding
um then you know it's a 30 000 base
genome so just look at it from the
different parameters I think that have
been talked about if you want to do a
minimum of a hundred thousand reads per
sample right say in the bottom end of
that that's really possible you will
generate an average of 3x coverage
around the genome this is certainly not
good enough or deep enough to upload
into gets Aid and certainly not uh
reliable enough for you know I would say
uh really high quality varying calling
so I think a hundred thousand if it's
just for some scanning right that's
probably fine but you shouldn't expect
to get you know high quality varying
calling now if you and that's a hundred
thousand paired entry so total reads
here of what I'm speaking about as you
move up to uh like 500 000 X coverage
right sort of sort of the next rung here
um now you again you're looking at about
15x coverage here this is still
um probably below the guess a cut off in
terms of the sequencing depth that you
need it's probably
um that is enough to um from published
uh indications
um and and actually we had a paper that
was published by Loma Linda University
using our original kit that showed that
500 000 reads at the bottom and was
enough to build consensus reads right so
I think at the bottom level that's
probably the minimum now as you go up to
the next run a million reads per sample
right again this is where you expect to
get about 30X coverage or maybe a little
bit higher right in terms of coverage
around average coverage around the gene
know this is sufficient right for our
consensus rebuilding for varying calling
um you know I wouldn't say that that is
ultra deep sequencing
um but then the next rung is sort of you
know two million and more reads right
which you know depending if you have a
super high throughput sequencer you may
actually you know not you may have too
much space
um to be able to to go out and to and to
sequence it
um there when you do really high def
sequencing
um right you essentially do I mean if
you as long as you have a significant
amount of input in right if you want to
do high depth sequencing and find novel
Kona types that's possible but that's
probably going to be something from a CT
with a very low CT value and a high
viral load right
um there's been Publications about
people who have been Amino compromised
who have high viral Fighters right that
they're looking for novel developing
clonotypes um that could be a scenario
where you would do ultra deep sequencing
right a million plus read sequencing or
to do more to be able to look at some of
those prototypes so
the answer is not very simple but it
really depends on what you want to do
and you know if it's face consensus
rebuilding I would start at 500 000
reads if it's varying calling you know
500 000 to a million and then if it's
you know really novel conotype
identification you know plus a million
reads is probably you know enough to be
able to start to look at some of those
things as they develop in some cases
very good thanks so much
um I think we are running a little bit a
few minutes over I think we have time
for one more question
um
says um what which is the cost
um for each Wastewater sample for NGS I
think this goes to Fernando in the case
of Brazil the omics network how much
money has been invested for sequencing
oh
well nowadays we have something like
200 million and 200 and a half million
uh uh dollars invested in our network
but we are looking for for more
investment for the next month but that's
that's mostly the the amount of money
that we have these days in Brazil one
sample is with uh of taijin and
complemented by alumni Solutions is
is nowadays on flight something like a
hundred dollars per sample let's say
that's but that's the typical case of
Brazil and uh at least from what I saw
from the Brian uh presentation I think
that we could lower the cost
if we have this solution because we have
all the flash Square badges
is sometimes very expensive and I think
that we have chances to to do much more
with lower costs maybe if we if you had
we had the chance to to pass through
this new Solutions of course
great very good thank you so much
um at this time I I do want to thank
both our attendees as well as our two
speakers Brian and Fernando uh for a
terrific presentation today
um there are a few questions that we
were not able to answer during their q a
and we will get back to those attendees
and with answers for you following the
presentation
um but again thank you so much for your
interest in this timely topic we hope
that you enjoyed today's presentation
and we invite you to come back and hear
more presentations from Kai
with that this concludes today's webinar
presentation again thank you and have a
great rest of your day